[Music]
often greatness carries with it the
cries of its admirers and those who
wield it make sure you know it everyone
else's trash what am I gonna do a title
I'll take the money but sometimes the
greatest among us let their actions
speak louder than words
[Music]
Johanna for they use snipe today you're
going to learn the story of silent
greatness of someone who walked out of
the shadows and took no prisoners
Joe Dyke he's got the Nana Musa Dagh be
crazy Jack someone who'll assassinate
you
without a sound this guy said Jana is
just insane this is the story of over
watches deadliest support Jonah this is
a guy in the name we have so often
because of how potent he is one night an
affable
this is the story of Joe Mack to find
the origin story of sung-hyun Joe knock
bang you've got to travel east to where
many of his forces most celebrated names
got their start with Ohio hella cool
no young and for solos a lot of eligible
typically hazel photos one nothing he
was a rebellious kid in a culture where
school is prioritized above almost
everything he neglected his studies and
by the time he reached his second year
of high school he decided to pursue his
passion gaining luckily on big money
till twelve oh and she ain't game buckle
come with after all being a pro gamer is
something he's always dreamed of to talk
with in a never told it on the Naboo
game all in the tofu and Joe knack quite
literally played everything that was put
in front of him at home to Patong came
to the home center dr. king came Petrov
all hungry Verizon any militant in Konya
Tom two people on one fateful day during
his second year of high school he and a
few friends stopped at a PC bang on
their way to an after school event and
he came across the game that would
change his life that coulda done due to
this on the the portal into my pocket a
to televise will go till to the LA Times
me Phyllis fool okay Chuck itself a
short time later his mother handed him
some pocket money as a small surprise
which he used to purchase his own copy
of the game it was on that day that
seung-hyun bong became Joe Mac Joe night
didn't have the same path to overwatch
as big as stage as many of his peers in
South Korea the overwatch scene began to
grow when it was still in open beta and
was first to establish its own
competitive scene apex
come to Intel overwatch APEC season 1
I'm dough if me is Monte Cristo here we
go man it's a new game it's over watch
it's gonna be epic
so naturally the world's greatest names
flocked to Korea in the hopes of
establishing themselves for whatever
competitive future
overwatch held names like Seagal tae Moo
and Ryu Jong used apex as a proving
ground to show that they had what it
took to dominate this new game oh I knew
where it was obviously carpe the carpe
do that tiger knew where he was you got
to expect that but van sometimes you
don't expect that level of accuracy
damage and though we've heard so much
about the into the sleep guys don't
worry about it fights off me and it was
there during the apex era where Joe Knox
pro career started but not where you
might expect not on stage playing
support but in the crowd cheering on his
close friend Kido as he hoisted the apex
trophy in season 3 what I did with the
Gunners or herbalism pedal to my p.m.
day and it was there in that arena that
he knew he wanted to give everything to
become a pro player Copeland's oh I love
a little careful with the tilt oh
there's nothing worth it in 2016
Blizzard had announced the overwatch
League at Blizzcon a year after the
game's release we're looking for the top
players in the world and the team owners
who will form the overwatch lean so
while everyone was over competing in
apex they now had their sights set on
something bigger a fully franchised and
geo-located league there will be a
combine where players attend tryouts and
will be evaluated by team owners and
coaches across a series of tests as the
original 12 teams were formed it was
time for them to pick up rosters today
is a day you all been waiting for its
roster reveal day
to help me announcer SF overwatch league
roster I've invited some new friends who
have joined the NRG plant oh yeah
there's been a lot of people talking
about the league roster we try blots of
amazing players from around the world
for many many months to put together
what we think is a b-17 Jonah had built
himself a reputation as a lethal support
player during that era he possessed all
the game sense and communication pro
teams wanted from a support but could
wield characters like zenyatta in a
proactive way that was very unusual even
at the highest level
[Music]
right behind right behind my eyes find
behind watch out Joe knack had star
power and the overwatch League took
notice some players for example like
mono Jonah and lavro
pavayne does a lot of those
recommendation it's pretty good at
scouting as you can obviously see from
no scouting Jonah as rosters were being
finalized for the inaugural season of
the overwatch League Joe knack was
plucked straight out of overwatch is
competitive in game ladder to become a
starting support for the New York
Excelsior de montejo play a Negro
community moon which cooked a container
top open oh oh don't even don't even
looking
unlike other eSports scenes that have
slowly crawled towards tangible
contracts and outside investment
overwatch League raced to it and what
that meant for the players was that
season one was a blank slate
sure Dallas had some of the biggest
names of the game and soul possessed
unbelievable individual skill but there
were so many question marks and when the
lights flashed on it was a team of
Koreans wearing blue that shocked the
league and in New York Excel will walk
it home on new Bonnie three two one
final score for New York excelsior it
seems like that has been a trend today
they did not disappoint
I nobody could be disappointed with
Pines performance but I think that
everybody else you know they really did
show and NYX L will take this series
three the one will be the victory for
New York a libero holding onto that
tactical visor and just waiting for the
Valkyrie at the end this is the most
clinical we have seen the excelsior so
far hate us down purely based on their
own play and the precision of their
teamwork this has been at their most
convincing victory New York got off to a
roaring four zero starter in season ones
first stage and looked like a well-oiled
machine
I think NY Excel is a top two team maybe
even the best in the world
they have Savior will be and pine making
highlight reel dps plays Reds come Zin
from NY Excel and here comes pine gets
one gets two looking for a bit more it
gets another one are you kidding me this
guy is gonna single-handedly change the
point back over mono and Mako holding it
down on the tank lines knifing the RIP
tire there of anomie that's a huge kill
you could have potentially saw the
higher-ups come and take ark out of the
sky but NY Excel turning up here 17
seconds left the Chili's trying to say
the support the Killa unko huge play
from echo arc has won support and of
course
sho'nac who filled out the roster in the
second supports law although with Joe
knack it feels wrong to associate him
with any traditional overwatch role
because when he plays it's like nothing
we've ever seen before
Widow dual showing half where the youth
snipe gets linked sir low force to pop
the wings now both sides now two
for New York Excel potty just follows
his brass trying to go for that res
outfit all the chaos not enough
distractions there he will not survive
it are hot now I'm just taking a poly as
well
Jonah heads him with a poke to the face
now for your average pro what that means
is pretty simple your job is to keep
your team alive land timely dis chords
and teamfights and pop your
transcendence ability just in time to
turn the tides of battle but for Jonah
zenyatta
is lethal load that's gonna be a problem
that's the thing Kujo nagging the kill
on his super sets it up for the rest of
his team to win this one it's fadeaway
or by the moth as he flees the fight and
that's gonna be New York holding on a he
can't get the translocator off at time
good bye Frankie though Chodak he's got
the Nano boo Saddam beat and crazy f2
notes down as well pops of transcendence
form echo Florida gets out of the way
Joe knack gets some space to come in
firing away at Samus I can't quite get
the kill down now turns his attention
onto swoosh a little bit low health
nearly take it off by that Winston and
he stays alive just barely got a run
though arc keeps him alive I think it's
not 9 HP there at one point in time but
he stays upright because closest it gets
a shot on his side play whoa sigh Flair
was ulti when it was sacked
that's right man attend down he was d
mekt didn't have a chance a live oh hey
they need to hold the gun he plays the
character and is positioned much
differently than any other support in
the league he's this healing sniper
hybrid balancing his role with his
ferocious aggression over to Lorelai
welcome back supporter granite Anna
Navarro and immune to lava Tyrion Newman
from Medicaid on Terra Cotta mo conde
Chicana by Allah if Kirito gonna crumble
devote all your potato crisps or talk to
prove us wrong not here throughout the
entirety of season 1 Joe knack led the
league in both damage and eliminations
for support players what's more is that
the way he played ended up defining the
way that New York played around him they
took a defensive tax to their strategic
approach they loved their opponents into
a false sense of security
absorbing pressure and going late into
fights this would then allow Jonah to
land the volleys they needed to take
down each fight one by one he learned it
from watching his hero a player he
modeled his game after and someone who
would become his greatest adversary in
the overwatch league
Ryu Jae Hong code I wanna cut it was of
Kabletown our national hospital condo
Comcast karate the cool and early in
stage 1 of season 1 he'd get to go
toe-to-toe with his either this is the
most likely method you will see far
before on on we checked our pockets dojo
to focus the target call here everything
is impeccable
the Kings
Pequod's again
tom was a geologist and so bottle of
Pellegrino - Latoya I'm Trent Watson and
it was there and then after New York
beats soul in stage one that it became
clear just how good they could be that
was the genesis of the concept of his
unbeatable in my Excel you know a
machine that soul was expected to be the
top team and New York ended up
prevailing against him from that moment
on they took no prisoners
they went nine and one during stage one
with an absurd plus twenty one map
differential but showed they were
beatable when they were bested by a
surging London Spitfire in the stage one
finals Last Man Standing
Oh deep ticking away and that is a
London Spitfire will be here overwatch
league stage one champions they followed
up their stage one performance with
another 91 split in stage two but this
time they closed the commitment being
that unite standing to another resurrect
is gonna be there it's popcorn this
brought back to the fine Charnock don't
see what could never go to remake never
I picked them up on the Widowmaker
turned out but he's been talking about a
healing in assess the eqo one man to
step up
[Applause]
[Music]
New York didn't stop there though they
wanted more and continued their
onslaught over the course of stage three
who is gonna make it back mistakes which
the Sabra but he can't touch the point
the stage two and three champions of the
old watch league team in time Oh Tim I
need you pull them on a Tuesday don't
people could ahem time John was a fool
after a 7-3 performance in stage four it
was time for the entire community to
look toward the playoffs where the first
ever overwatch League champions would be
crowned
despite rumblings about the surging
Philadelphia fusion and London's great
roster New York were the odds-on
favorite to take home the crown but for
New York in season one it wasn't meant
to be
the blade is out there getting all the
kills in the world and it is last-second
self-destruct this is it
[Applause]
win over New York excel in the first
match of this semifinal Philadelphia
fusion half they've done it have they
set themselves to the overwatch League
grand finals I think they may have they
have DeLarge the only one
heartbreak struck joinin do Matalan
dream analogy war and rumba terrible
Samuel Hammond a tango near Palm Cove
enemy Brittany Jessamine enjoy a prison
John even do get also on Monday today
show you home in a solemn tone to keep
on kilometres between you and a devil
triger and booty so pop Angola I am so
sorry about you will come one day home
to my name was Mary Jo nag and the New
York excelsior hoped to have their day
in the Sun but that day was not going to
be in the overwatch league's inaugural
season without any further ado I present
to you the inaugural overwatch League
MVP in a bittersweet celebration at the
end of the season that Joe knack was
named the season one MVP he
revolutionized his position and
performed with jaw-dropping consistency
all year long better baby - into what
Jonah does that is three kills for the
Batman on sunyata not over yet he's
whatever bar yeah they had to wait for
the barrier that's why it took so long
for par 5
for Ark and now they are going to charge
forward into the Spitfire oh man sho'nac
by the book finding the kills but
another one comes in he's got it on
cooldown now in just a few seconds here
playing it safe now
yeah but the tanks are on the point oh
if it finds lib row though Shack I can't
believe it's effect to this guy's said
Jana is just insane alright how do you
going I'm JD great the wingman
that's obviously Joe neck to be greater
than have to say something off with him
but there was more to it than that the
New York Excelsior had grown in ways
that didn't stop when the payload
stopped moving you see when it's the
first year of this massively and teams
are thrown together and you fly to
another country with hopes of glory it's
difficult for fans to put a face to your
name and what New York did in season one
was build themselves and their fan base
into more than just an overwatch team
and Jonah was right at the center of
that why did you have the debt to Jonah
he looks like on the aliens on Kamino
baking Coronas from towers I'm human
Joan acts the type of superstar that
sometimes feels ice-cold
he's never shook onstage win or lose he
remains calm and it's that kind of
nonchalant attitude that I click heads
like this four hundred dollar bills
swagger that has made New York one of
the most beloved teams in the world but
I'll tell you
New York Excelsior is a very different
kind of team because they've probably
got one of the most personable sets of
individuals that you can have they've
become known as the team with the custom
Air Force Ones and Balenciaga sneakers
they've collabed with New York legacy
streetwear brand undefeated and haven't
shied away from showing some of that
on camera they've made it so no matter
how they perform who's in the starting
lineup or where they're playing you know
what the New York Excelsior stand for
outside of his matches Joe knack has
become known for the uncanny
similarities between him and his
character of choice Zenyatta his fans
quite literally flocked to YouTube to
watch him meditate on stream for all
intents and purposes Joe knock feels
like the kind of guy that would be
passed over by fans he's not in your
face or loud but there's something
infatuating about his signature round
glasses and often redyed bowl-cut he's
just cool even in silence and that's
enough for his fans I wish I looked as
cool as Joan that does good that kid is
just so much swagger it hurts all Gucci
slides and adidas aside New York had a
job to do a season two approached Santa
noon tebah soon first own decision MVP
no flippin because I listen this year
there'd be eight more teams to compete
with and it was time they made amends
for a missed opportunity in the season 1
playoffs but early on in season 2 all
eyes were on another all Korean roster
dominating in a similar fashion to the
way New York had just a year earlier to
quickly grab not working
manages to get the 4k the type but the
crucial play at the very end I think
slime might have gotten a poop there
himself as well to set that up any way
you slice it that's gonna be Vancouver
Titans taking the series combo time and
they will win it for sideburns inking it
from the fact that shatter comes down
good night
brutal savage Brecht of course the
Titans went fully undefeated in stage 1
of season 2 that said New York matched
them step by step
they're tough in the ground of night
sound barrier for New York all fields
coming online in just right time Heather
said Rob to the payload it's going to
seal the deal and NY Excel they will
stop Boston's progress right here so
many naysayers they had an easy schedule
they say this is not their matter they
say New York will not excel whether it's
in their name and that is exactly what
they do does not have the D matrix and
toss out
Grand Slam for New York but then they
came up against the sole dynasty they
can't do anything over the this has
become the biggest [ __ ] in the armor
for joe nack and New York despite their
overwhelming success you can't help but
notice their propensity for playing down
to the level of their competition and in
this way they've taken some pretty ugly
losses take it down Charnock in the pack
the team white comes to Atlanta raid no
draws here they get it with a 3-0 the
first team to take down NYX out
against all odds no one expected us no
one predicted this they've remained one
of the best teams in the overwatch
league throughout the first two stages
of season two but are nestled just below
Vancouver and San Francisco in the minds
of most top analysts the weird thing is
I think they match up well against the
Vancouver Titans so like Brent saying
perhaps if I'm being real maybe they
don't belong in the top three just based
on the fact that other teams in the mid
table I think you're gonna find it
easier to beat New York frankly New York
has a lot to prove right now so he was
you know
since our target thought Paul to get
what a lot of us lose the meta game has
shifted from the dive centric offensive
play style we saw last year to one where
tanks and supports reigned supreme and
this shift hasn't helped Joe knack I
feel like the reason I say that Joe lock
is the weak point for for New York right
now is because their playstyle is so
invested in here alone
right they want to pump all their
reasons into it the armor pack the
bubbles everything what's left for the
front line then is getting obliterated
time and time again because of this play
stuff during season two he's had to
spend more time playing onna rather than
Zenyatta
and the three tank three support
compositions that he's playing a
maturity of the time rely much more on
his transcendence than his ability to
click heads a couple of players have
fallen they lose a couple of the
majority to turn a four v65 with the
transcendence now sometimes this is good
but at the end of the day over
competences of flimsy shields and you
can see where they would have nice
ultimate like they could have used his
transcendence right here in the
following teamfight as stage 2 came to a
close they finally got their shot
against Vancouver in the semi-finals
subha sensei Garmadon and a given Ganges
in berea pour TOI you go horizontally
but they just couldn't match up to the
league's best coach team they got run
over
the Titans they're gonna get it done
first babs goes the way of the Vancouver
Titans
start that they were looking for this
semifinal Joe neg did man she got the
trance off but it doesn't really matter
his teammates are going down at the
bakery Titans are looking like they are
going to get the job done here
Lucy was gonna get there but he's not
gonna be happy to see what it is
Vancouver Titans going back to the stage
finals so for the New York excelsior a
lot of this season hangs on the
shoulders of their star once more that
we can take a look at Jim have gotten
bay now you know we see that Jayhawks
play beats it out of a junker town in
one look at this guy it's just a
blessing it's sick right so on man let's
just watch this one again
Oh heels with the get she deals with the
tracer configuration takedown Vinny's
firing the second tick field gonna be
there Joe oh man this takes it down
right up in the face of a bastion finds
a triple kill
Espino and art also father let's go
ahead and bake it for Vince he got bored
for me George let's go ahead and say it
times gonna be done for the Bob gonna
make a packet but there it is get some
in the face and then why excel just take
the point of a backup Jonah
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]